check this out we got the story from
timcast.com oh
okay we gotta be careful on this one
because i don't know if i can read this
quote from joe biden it's against
youtube's rules
i'll read it anyway and tell you um
before i do
joe biden the president is giving
medical misinformation
if i were to assert what joe biden said
youtube would delete this video as per
youtube's rules
joe biden falsely claims you're not
gonna get
coveted if you have been vaccinated that
is not true
absolutely not true we've already seen
breakthrough cases
people who are vaccinated against
getting sick i think it was um
was it uh uh bill maher oh mario yeah he
was vaccinated they did
cancel his show now we have restaurants
shutting down um
joe biden the president of the united
states is is is espousing
medical misinformation my friends uh so
this is for timcast.com
we say i guess we put we we say we now
because not they during a town hall on
wednesday night president biden claimed
that people who have received vaccines
will not get covet 19
after fully vaccinated white house
officials have recently been infected
with the virus oh yeah
he said quote the various shots that
people are getting now cover that
you're okay you're not going to get
coveted if you have these vaccinations
that is wrong that is wrong youtube
see you heard us we're saying joe biden
is incorrect
and joe biden the president and the
white house are giving medical
misinformation and bad information
we're doing what you want us to do
youtube sensors abundant statements come
after multiple fully vaccinated democrat
lawmakers and modest officials
have become infected with the virus
beginning with the texas democrats who
fled their state
to stop legitimate democratic processes
the texas democrats first met with a
pelosi staffer who became infected
so now i think the latest we saw was
like a handful of white house staffers
that i i don't think the texas democrats
are going to give any more updates on
how many of their delegations
stopped yeah because it was like 11 of
their delegation had already become you
know coveted positive
and now you know joe biden goes on cnn
and he gives this bunk information
i'm wondering if youtube is going to ban
biden over this you know they
twitter banned trump i mean trump was
relentless and i don't know how much
how many tweets did he put out that were
wrong but wrong about what i don't know
just
misinformation i guess would you say
countless countless 10
20 100. i mean i don't know i wasn't
following you know i'll tell you this
you look at twitter and you look at joe
biden you look at trump and it's just
like static it's like looking at an old
tv
i if you guys are out there listening
don't ban him for this
don't ban joe biden for saying this
thing i mean he
acknowledged that maybe it's wrong maybe
put a thing on there that
how much how how how long until like you
know fauci comes out and actually says
oh actually
you know cdc guy like joe biden was
right the whole time apparently he's not
don't ban us joe biden is wrong it's the
weirdest thing so there was a study from
oxford
talking about a particular medication i
won't say because youtube will manage
oh my gosh it's ridiculous yeah and uh
uh
i emailed google like
in order to talk about this do i have to
say that oxford is wrong
and the science is wrong and they were
like just make sure you provide adequate
context and i'm like i don't believe you
like the rules explicitly say that you
can't say there are certain treatments
for kovid
but oxford came out the study saying
they may there may
may and i'm like i can't even talk about
that so i love i love the the sheer
absurdity that is youtube
back when all of this first started i
did a video about it
it was when everything was going crazy
in wuhan and it wasn't spreading
anywhere else
and youtube actually demonetized that
and they told me no
you can't talk about this and i was like
it's news you know what i mean it's
really weird
and then like a couple weeks later like
okay actually yeah you can't talk about
it and i was like okay
so this this is the problem with
censorship that these big tech platforms
do
by choosing you know to to with like
to ban certain information it's very
likely because they're not experts
soon that information will actually turn
to be correct or important
and then they've had ban they've banned
it and we got to go back and change it
yeah that's that's that's that's where
we're at with communist america and big
tech and youtube
so i don't know the information war is
upon us i
used to think that was more of a more of
a an allegory
or is that the right word for it uh i
would i would say it was it sounded like
hyperbole when alex jones was first
talking about it but i think it's a good
assessment that it is 100 an information
war that fifth generational warfare
we're seeing now
i love being able to have a debate about
an idea where one person has bad
information and the other person is able
to correct them and you can see the
process because then other people that
have the bad information also get to be
part of that process
right so that's why i'm turned off by
you know censoring things that are wrong
or i i want to make sure i'm being fair
to joe biden because
it may not be that he's wrong okay it
may just be that he doesn't know how to
put
words together that is true oh yeah so
in another story
i don't know if you guys watched the
town hall this is uh from the daily mail
they say quote the experts say we know
that this virus is
in fact uh um uh it's gonna be or
excuse me biden loses his thoughts on
vaccines flubs answer on his foreign
policy work
and falsely tell salt down all you won't
get coveted if you have the shot that is
incorrect
can't watch so i think the dude just
isn't isn't with it
you know i think most people realize
that by now
help me
[Laughter]
look i mean obviously we know you know
we know what joe biden's
strengths and weaknesses particularly
weaknesses are
right now at this advanced age stage of
his presidency
i mean i was always of the belief that
kamala harris
is really running a lot of the show on
joe biden especially with regards to his
racial policy his equity policy
everything like that
i mean say what you want about joe biden
being ineffective but all that does is
that makes kamala harris
and her agenda even more effective well
so
so you know your book is about
meritocracy yeah
and i don't even i'm we're sitting here
like we know that you have this book and
talking about stuff and i can only
assume you probably don't like joe biden
but i don't know i mean maybe you love
the guy but you hate critical race
theory
wow i mean i look joe biden here's the
thing
he he did something he he was
he was the candidate that was able he
was the only candidate that the
democrats could
run that was able to win back the trump
voters i was able to win back some of
the trump voters that that's that that's
what i think about joe biden and he did
isn't it crazy
true we lost white men yeah yeah you
know trump
won more hispanics
more asians more black people
than than he did in 2016 you know this
supposed racist everything like that
won all of these groups more effectively
the only place that the polls the exit
polls show he lost was white men
[Laughter]
what do you think about regarding
meritocracy is you've written a book on
it and
and the fact that we have a government
or at least
the top of our government the president
where we vote people in based on
popularity
not necessarily merit and
so i want to know well there's merit in
there isn't there not necessarily you
can have some dumb idiot that everyone
loves that becomes president
doesn't have any idea what they're doing
because he's the most popular well
that's the thing is that's what some
people think about trump
they think he's just a dumb idiot but i
think he has genuine merit
he is probably the most effective
marketing
salesperson that we have you know that
i've ever seen
in my lifetime on the campaign trail
you're saying that he is the the
greatest president of all time
i'm saying he's the greatest marketing
strategist of all time
yeah do you think there's something we
could do better with our government so
that we could get
more merit at the top well you know they
they
here's the thing about our political
system and in this in this this
correlates kind of with meritocracy
um i i take different definitions of
merit so i don't think that the person
who wins the president should be the
person with the most degrees or the
person who's
supposedly done the most for our country
or whatever the person has to really
connect with the people and i think that
our system our political system
flawed as it is still gives the people
the ability
to to make judgments on themselves you
know to
choose the president and i think that
that that's worth preserving
so you think that the president's main
job is to connect with the people
not so much to be the best or at any one
thing right i mean
i mean the president originally
functioned he has a cabinet and that's
where he
brings in all of the best people and
everything like that that's his choice
but he has to be able to connect he's
the executive
right the executive isn't necessarily
the smartest person in the room the
executive is the person who can connect
all of the dots
and form it into a larger vision that's
what trump did
probably most effectively he was able to
create
that vision make america great again
keep america great 2016
that that that you resonated with
a segment of the populace the republican
party had historically
not been able to resonate with well i
think that is meritorious that's very
very
absolutely yeah and uh the one problem
was that
you know merit can go into a bunch of
different directions was trump able to
rally people
and and win an election yep does it show
merit of course
less you know hillary clinton had less
she lost however
when it came to actually administrating
trump didn't have it
and that's why he ended up for a variety
of reasons i'll say one of the reasons
he ended up not winning a re-election
though we'll see what happens next once
people realize that biden was actually
the worst choice
but um one of the problems was the
people he surrounded himself with mark
milley for instance
yeah this this is a guy that trump
should have gotten rid of a long time
ago
dr fauci trump didn't have he should
have fired these people
john bolton oh man he hired the guy he
still
showed his political neophyte instincts
when he chose rex tillerson as the
secretary of state i mean they obviously
could not
connect from the very start he started
to be a little better towards the end
in terms of his administrative picks but
you could tell at the very beginning
he was he was he was too hewn
to the republican party and their
instincts instead of being able to go
with what his vision was
and that harmed him because he only has
four years you only have four years
president that's nothing
that's no time at all she over here does
not have four years xi jinping does not
have four years he has 30 years to do
whatever he wants and remake china's own
in his own is that how long it lasts 30
years no i mean and so you
you get deposed or you die or you retire
oh they get elected for life
you don't get elected for life but you
can you can
extend your supposed constitutional
authority however long you really want
to
are they appointed by the party they are
yes and it's like a group of people at
the top of the party decide
uh-huh yes yeah that that's yeah this is
that's
it's a totally different system in china
than it is in the us
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you